so where did the time line fracture get
us a professor Eck's who swears hey guys
I don't really have a particular impetus
for this the latest trailer for Logan
came out a little while ago I didn't
really do a video on that directly I did
one about the first trailer that came
out but I'm not necessarily talking
about the trailers specifically I'm sort
of using it as a leaping off point to
talk about some stuff that's been talked
about since then and just in general to
talk about the continuity of this
particular film and this franchise as a
whole things have gotten a little bit
weird I and actually I'm part of what
I'm gonna complain about I have
contributed to because some things were
said when the first trailer hit where I
it basically said this is set in the
same timeline as Days of Future past
that the epilogue bit in that just a
little bit done why I didn't like that
because it means that whatever happy
ending we got at the end of that got
robbed from us and everyone's dead now I
didn't care for that but it's now very
up in the air and we're getting
contradictory things in terms of where
Logan actually fits in terms of
continuity so is it actually set after
days of future passes it's set after the
epilogue of Days of Future past is it
later on in the revised timeline Days of
Future past which would make it I
suppose a follow-up to apocalypse is it
said somehow in the original timeline
before everything got messed up which
would make a sequel to The Wolverine
most directly and fans some fans are
really going nuts trying figure out
where this fits how does this work and
you kind of got a stop see here's the
thing about series continuity we now
that comic book movies are a thing and
continuity between those movies is
actually a very big thing and tightly
maintained now we've kind of gotten
spoiled for continuity you would like we
want everything to fit perfect and we're
geeks we pick stuff apart but not every
franchise is built for that some very
actually deliberately don't go out of
their way to have continuity they don't
go out of their way to come
predict things but they're not they're
not there to make everything line up a
good example of that is the Mad Max
franchise now George Miller over the
maker of every single bad Maxim has said
flat out yet there isn't really a
continuity you can't track it from one
film to the next and have it completely
line up and yet even when the maker of
that film said yet they're not supposed
to all fit together completely I would
still see you know forum posts and
videos and whatever of people with these
theories like oh that Tom Hardy isn't
actually max because max was Mel Gibson
no Tom Hardy is the feral kid from that
earlier movie and they try and knit it
and make it this perfect continuous
continuity and while sometimes that can
be a fun exercise we need to accept that
it's completely unnecessary and actually
oftentimes we kind of ruin these things
for ourselves by picking apart things
that aren't meant to be picked apart now
under normal circumstances I would kind
of lump Logan under that unfortunately
the x-men franchise is a bit of an odd
duck because not only has there been
some continuity but across the film's
supposedly it's it doesn't hold up very
well but they've been trying and more
the point there are some entries in the
franchise Days of Future past being the
first one that really springs to mind
that has gone out of its way to be
basically about the continuity or about
altering it so when you literally have
an entry in the film that is all about
the continuity you can't really go the
continuity doesn't matter and yet that
seems to be what director James mangle
and Hugh Jackman seem to be doing
they're kind of going look this is like
an alternate timeline or they're being
vague or they're just they're dead what
they want to do I get the sense is they
want to throw their hands up it goes
please stop worrying about the
continuity just watch the movie and
that's kind of the headspace I want to
come at this from and and it's not the
fault of this filmmaker and this star
that the franchise that they're making
this film in has a completely screwed up
continuity it's not their fault so maybe
I can I can forgive Logan on this and
and as I think about it I actually like
that approach
and I like that feel in terms of coming
at it so I like that it seems like and
we'll know better once the movie finally
comes out but it seems like what
happened was they said here's the story
we're going to tell and they basically
were given the freedom to disregard how
it would have had to knit into earlier
continuity he's like well here's the
story we're gonna tell well nobody we
got to change it because in an earlier
movie this was established so we need to
change that no that will make the story
worse we're not gonna do that to heck
with your continuity we're doing this
that's the vibe I'm getting and that's
probably gonna result in a better film
than if it was overly continuity
obsessed when you are too caught up in
continuity in terms of you know dealing
with threads you left before and setting
up stuff for future homes that's when
you get amazing spider-man to a movie
that feel more like franchise management
than it did actually telling a story so
I am glad that they for this film they
seem to be taking the opinion of look
we're gonna tell the best story we
possibly can especially since this might
be Hugh Jackman's last howdy as
Wolverine for my money he'll he'll
probably cameo in Deadpool or x-force or
something but it's probably his last
time leading a film as Wolverine that's
my bad it looks good I'm excited to see
x-23 see what they do with it let's
enjoy this thing because honestly at
this point I'm genuinely excited I
really liked the Wolverine and even
though the x-men franchise really kind
of fell on its face with apocalypse I'm
I'm actually excited about this movie
III don't really get excited off just
one trailer anymore for the most part
because it it's happened a number of
times where first trailer intrigues me
and then a later trailer either spoils
too much or it shows me an angle that
I'm like oh that could be the thing
that's the problem and I I haven't seen
that with Logan I'm just seeing
something makes me go I really want to
see that so thoughts on the latest Logan
trailer thoughts on the continuity of
the x-men movie whatever you got drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe hit that little bell down
there so you get notifications when new
stuff goes up follow me on twitter our
council of geeks check out the council
geeks podcast available on itunes
and stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned